Before we look at some examples,
there are few things that we need to consider when compiling threads.
First make sure to include the pthread header file, pthread.h, in your main
file that contains the pthreads code, otherwise your program will not compile.
Second, make sure to link your program with the pthreads library by
passing the lpthread flag at compile time.
On certain platforms, the better option is to use a pthread instead as a flag,
which tells the compiler to link the pthreads library as well as
to configure the compilation for threads.
If you don't link the library your program may not report
certain compilation errors at compile time, but it will still fail.
And finally, it's always a good idea to check the return values on
common functions like when you're creating threads,
creating variables, initializing certain data structures.
This is a good programming practice in general, but it's extra useful when
dealing with, all the [INAUDIBLE] of writing multithreaded programs.